and niho great with the mouse speed he's
just gonna move quickly oh
my gosh
oh he scared him
there are no words
nihal sarin has tremendously impressed
in 2022 he was runner-up in the
chess.com Global championship and an
individual gold medalist for India at
the Olympiad
Hikaru nakamura's resume speaks for
itself four-time speed chess champion
and reigning Fisher random world
champion are just a small fraction of
his accolades
would Nihao be able to capitalize on his
excellent 2022 and top everything off by
defeating the number one seated Hikaru
and becoming a speed Chess Championship
finalist
game one set the tone that all the chess
fans were looking for as Nihao offered a
brilliant sacrifice on move 18. you
could even sack on e4 let's open you
should some more and you absolutely
should take twice and bring the Rook to
C2 and I'm shocked that White's not
getting mated here according to the Eva
of artikaru might have to play Bishop E2
after Queen takes E4 check and give up
the house on the king side just to ask
that King is it gonna go up to D2 in
which case Rook a to C6 and we'll try to
go to C2 but no he does the I think the
very pragmatic thing here done it makes
draw we're tired what a game in an
equalish position in the second game
Hikaru took a long thing and made a
daring choice to play for a win with
Bishop C8 in nihal's time trouble and as
the Cairo drops behind on the clock he
actually goes for Bishop back to C8
opening up more pressure on the E4 pawn
and look at this he pushes the pawn up
to D3 now you can see what neho is
trying to do he's trying to go G3 but
that doesn't solve any problems the
Knight is a million strongholds and
there comes
if the king went to the H file this is
over Knight F4 it's one zero one
hits the rook and threads Rook H1 mate
that is resign time and actually it's a
win on time one H3 4g4 seven Knight H4
openings do not get more unorthodox than
hikaru's choice in game three would his
efforts be rewarded and they all just
desperately trying to complicate the
game this is obviously unsound I think
Hikaru can just take and go Rook B1 and
I don't see a follow-up here for black I
think he's just down a piece there is no
Bishop F4 giving up the Rook on A1
I like that decision as well get those
minor pieces off the board the white
king is safe and sound right now a queen
trade goodbye
wow good cry a car could have traded
queens and won that game very simply and
said he wins on the spot that's a
hanging piece ikaru Nakamura a man on a
mission playing H3 and H3 leading to
Victory after consecutive losses nihal
got his feet under him with the better
side of a pair of draws before a funny
finish to game six
and the bishop end game was winning now
the pawn moves forward to E5
is right back in this match Hikaru
cannot believe it hey Carl laughed that
blunder off and was right back to
pressing with white in the next game
could he win the queen in game by
trading off the ladies oh my gosh
Queenie Queen E4 Queenie Queen E4 oh
whatever it's by you if we misses it and
he goes wrong chances again oh my God
yes look at him he is absolutely I was
gonna say a bad word he is displeased
with himself right now
having missed that chance Hikaru could
only try to win by marching his King up
the board sacrificing his King side
Queen F7 is King running to f8 oh my God
oh my God
F5 ba Queen there's no checks there's
not a single check
the least likely Square on the
chessboard and that's where he went oh
my gosh and now he doesn't even need to
trade Queens he could have but he's
gonna win these pawns and oh wait but
there's still a bunch of checks here oh
my gosh it's still not over
yeah he's got everything he wants he's
connected G5 hangs oh what defensive
resilience by nehal but it's not quite
enough and Hikaru steals it in exactly a
hundred moves Nihao missed a chance in
game 8 as a draw closed out the five
plus one time control with Hikaru
leading me how 5-3 but Nihao was getting
opportunities he just needed to
capitalize on more of them
with time to collect himself in the
break Hikaru first held a draw against
Nihao and then broke his momentum in the
second three plus one game winning a
rook end game with black and then he
went to work pressing with white another
Blood sight by Neo and it stops Knight
takes F2 there's no defended Square on
this diagonal and at this point Black's
position collapses and nehal resigns the
game yeah and he is really upset look at
the car he's like next let's get the
next one going a four-point lead for
Hikaru could anyone in the world come
back from that deficit one of nihao's
greatest strengths is his ability to
come back and he did get a chance for
Brilliance in the next game oh my God
what a move no no Rook H5 Queen D4 Queen
F2 oh my gosh what a move one he goes
he's winning it's over holy sh oh my God
cheese balls look at those pawns on the
sixth record six Space Invaders up there
and if I heard Nakamura is going down
Rook B1 what a cold-blooded way to end
and what a brilliant comeback win for
nihal nihal also claimed a big in-game
Edge in the following game but Hikaru is
maybe the best defender on the planet
and he held on again by the hair on his
shinny Chin Chin Hikaru manages to pull
out the drug don't miss rookie three and
look at itaro he's wasting a few extra
seconds like look at this
he didn't promote right away he spent
some time the sixth three plus one game
Saw Nihao with a totally winning
position but then Insanity ensued but he
finds Knight C3 instead but what's the
difference
Queen he put her to screen no way
the car was gonna win this or maybe not
he could lose this story Robert that
tells you how winning White's position
was he blundered a queen and it's still
not that clear wait Bishop D five orbit
should be seven but Bishop is pg6 Bishop
Queen G6 to B1 oh my gosh he plundered
oh
that is a Backbreaker
oh my gosh
how does he do it
that was an absolute disaster for nihal
and even the greatest players in history
would struggle to recover but knee
helped immediately bounced back with a
win and followed that with some great
attacking play
despite disasters nihal had come back
from being down four points and he split
the three plus one time controls but he
was still down by two could he beat
Hikaru in bullet
nihal had a Winning Edge in the first
bullet game but things petered out into
a dead drawn position and then something
ridiculous happened
Hikaru is a grizzled veteran of the SEC
format he knows that there's not going
to be a quick draw and nihal great with
the mouse speed he's just gonna move
quickly oh
my gosh
oh he scared him
there are no words he just scared him
and he won the rook and won the game and
now he has a three-point lead
that was an absolute back breaker of A
Swindle from Hikaru and He piled on with
two more cleaner wins to follow up and
extend his lead to five games
with little time remaining it was
already difficult to see Nihao coming
back even if everything went his way but
Hikaru is a master at draining time off
of the clock and he did just that in a
long draw before nihal did get winning
chances in the next Rook end game
he finally wins a bullet game Hikaru
bounced back with another win and then
Nihao snagged one but there was only
enough time left for one more game
so even H6 draws
oh well that's
concludes the match Hikaru Nakamura goes
through to the speed chess championship
finals and will play the winner between
the reigning world chess champion Magnus
Carlson and the reigning world Blitz
chess champion Maxime vashier lagrav
foreign
[Music]